REI leaned on you today for what should
the message be from the White House to
American companies and workers at this
point well it always has to be two parts
one is reassurance so people don't go
too far and think that the worst is
going to happen when it's not but to
absolute realism people want to be
leveled with they want to be told how
dangerous is it how safe is my family
what do I need to do those are the two
things that the administration must do
each and every single day and do you
think that that has happened to this
point I do and you know this criticism
that the president is getting he's
getting it because he's president
trumpet that's why they're piling on I
think any president would be going
through a very difficult period when the
facts are like they are in a case like
this the only criticism I have is I
think the president got stuck in India
one day too late if he had come back one
day earlier I think he'd have been ahead
of this storm that all of a sudden
gathered it was the day an official from
the CDC said it's not a question of if
it's a question of when that message
alarmed everybody and it's really what
launched us to where we are today that's
interesting I haven't exactly heard
maybe I've missed it across you know
many people talking about this that
there was a point in time that you saw
that the messaging needed to shift and
so where are we going now with this it
you know we get this 5:00 p.m. Eastern
daily briefing now at least that's
starting to tick up it looks like with
some regularity what kind of messaging
with what regularity really needs to
come and and from whom do we need as
many voices telling us things of the the
problem is fear and the problem is
confidence those in and eight worries
that people have those are driven really
by just what they're hearing what
they're seeing what's on social media
and so therefore it's the responsibility
of the president and all the experts
that he's surrounded with daily and
they're the best right experts to try to
address the confidence and the fear
questions and that means calm realistic
accurate expressions from the White
House it means the President to send
that broadest signal of reassurance and
the experts to talk on the level of
here's exactly what's happening this
will start to reverse when the science
gets ahold of it that's difficult part
Harris you don't know how long that is
until the medicine works the vaccine
comes in next year but between now and
then science will have a lot to do with
it and so little time and nature these
things peter out we hope it Peters out
fast